Hey guys, we hope you're safe. We hope you're healthy. Welcome back to Versus One
Even though we're practicing social distancing
That doesn't mean you can't form new connections
We are proud to partner with Bumble for this special virtual episode of Versus One
We used the Bumble app and their in-app video chat feature to bring one lady together with 20 lucky guys and to see if
We can find a perfect match
And just like us they're looking forward to the time when they can once again be together in person, but until that time
Stay safe out there and enjoy this video.
Here they come
Hey, I'm Leesie Pinto, I'm 21 years old and I currently am a student in Los Angeles
Yeah, what is your dating life been like during quarantine?
Non-existent at all
Ayden, 21. Okay. He has some nice hair
He's a singer, piano player. I'm tryna learn piano. Six foot, great
Active. Leo- ooh Leo.
Okay. Okay Oh
Aw he's playing a lil guitar.
Swiping right. Boom.
Juan.
I'm gonna have to swipe left. I'm so sorry
David Allen, are you in here? Oh, you're so cute. Okay space cowboy. Did you know that "Krampus" is just "Sup Mark" backwards?
He's 6'1" nice. He's cute I like him I'm gonna swipe right
Nice. Film composer, nice. A master of oversharing sometimes cries while listening to Finding Me
I like that. I like your profile picture. You look studious
All right. I'll swipe right? Okay. Okay
Favorite quality in a person, ambition
Favorite quality in a person, humor. Me too. Open-mindedness?
Yes. Understand? YES. Spongebob? You got it all going
Exactly.
You're six eight
Yes
Jesus and you're cute
Ay, thank you.
Two truths, one lie, ooh I love these. I'm a semi-pro soccer player
I'm gonna have to swipe left on you Stephen. I'm so sorry
Yes, the third picture of you in that costume. Everything.
I feel like when we get along and you're cute so I'm gonna swipe right.
Brian I feel like we would get along more as friends than
Romantically.
Oh you're an artist, a student, a traveler
A Christian. Love.
You like good food a nice drink. Me too.
I would definitely swipe right on you. You're really cute
So are you shirtless with all of your friends?
It was- okay. It was Fourth of July
So everybody in the room was like in their swimwear okay
No, yeah, I'll swipe right on you Jason.
Joanie you're just cute as hell so
I'm gonna swipe right
Nice, Evan. Okay 22
Wait you're Costa Rican?
Yeah, I'm actually, I have family from Costa Rica
Nice, you seem super sweet, but like I would want to be your friend. Not date you
Oh, yeah, I could understand. Okay. Thank you, though. You're welcome
Honestly, I was pretty nervous about the whole experience
But it was honestly a lot of fun. Whoever gets a first date after quarantine with her is gonna be a one lucky man
You'll send the same first message to every single
Send, okay
Let me put my glasses on for this so I can see
haha
"Success is making your family proud
not just how you make money, but how you love, respect, and devote yourself to them. Success is being a good dad."
My heart!
Ooh this is a paragraph.
"That's something I think about a lot actually, First, success for me means being able to support myself, my family my friends"
[audio effect]
I want to leave something behind that can be remembered and appreciated"
"I think success to me means reaching a point in my life where I'm not bothered to compare myself to other people"
Okay, okay, okay. First person I eliminated with Sam like I agree with the whole thing um-
This is so hard! I just feel like there were more detailed, I guess, responses
No hard feelings.
Sharuk.
Awwh, it's all good.
Aaaah this is so cruel.
Um, the next one is Chris.
You said "Setting the best example I can for everyone I meet on my journey I think if we all work together we can succeed together."
I love that. I think we all need to work together
But is that the only thing you define as success?
I think success can be in any aspect of life and every minute of every day
So, you know, you should just be doing what's the best you can to be the best version of yourself?
I love that, but umm..
You're good, don't trip, don't trip
Okay, the next one is Alec
Kevin.
Awh, it's okay.
I'm sorry Kevin.
No, that's all right
It's a bummer she don't want to go further and that's totally fine. There's nine billion of us human beings out there
I have to understand that nott everyone's gonna be into me and she has to go after
Whatever she's into
This is called the video chat or crib tour
So Lissie's going to video call you guys in Bumble
Is everyone really quickly cleaning their room right now. Oh, yeah
Oh, here's a secret. Here's a secret. Your room is you should always be clean.
OOOH. Atta boy.
Hi Malcolm.
Ah yeah so this is my room, like the current state. I've played basketball my whole life so there's a lot of basketball posters there.
The lights
[Inaudible]
Over here is like uh, a little living room area
I like sitting here and watching movies
Oh wow so your walls are lime green
It used to be my sister's room! I'm just too lazy to paint it, it doesn't bother me, you know
So this is my living area, my living room, because my room's a little dirty
So, so, this is my living room I actually live in an apartment near my campus
Biggest thing is the record collection, that's like a big thing for me
Yeah I mean, I got some music stuff. I got a keyboard, a guitar. I got a saxophone in my closet.
[Inaudible]
Ohp he's running, he's running
Going upstairs. Alright this is the outside, this is the rooftop
Dang! You got there so fast. Wait I think we live by each other
That's my like camera set-up, I make videos and stuff like that like
Like PG-13 videos, not like, you know whatever
Got a football
This is like my bed
Your bed looks hella comfy
My boxing gear. Oh you box?
Yeah yeah I like to stay active and I box a lot.
I want to learn how to box so badly
Wait, do you play any instruments or are you- Yeah.
I'm learning the piano right now but it's hard. Same.
Well maybe I'll teach you someday. Please!
I'm Christian, and I think this picture just exemplifies my faith and what I want to be like
[Inaudible]
Wait, where is your bed?!
I know, I know it's a thing. I took it out because my back has been hurting.
I've been sleeping on the floor for like over a year
What??
And then I have a pet and I we'll see if this is a red flag or not because
my pet is a snake
That's probably gonna be a no, I understand
My roommate in the back loves it though
Drew.
My snake, right? The snake bro I'm scared of snakes. It's understandable. It's one way or the other
David.
Damn it! I knew it
I'm sorry
Darius.
Yeaaah, felt it coming. It's all good
Okay, it's okay it's okay.
I think me sprinting to my roof it's not really a good look
But again, you miss 100% of the shots you don't take so
Jason.
Skylar.
Your room was awesome dude but um-
It's okay don't explain I don't wanna hear it
I've had my snake since I was a kid
He's been with me all my life growing up. So it's uh
He's an important part of my life and I was pretty surprised how
Non-competitive the atmosphere was. It wasn't toxic and I thought there might have been some toxic energy with, there's so many guys
For 20 versus one.
All right, this brings us to our finals.
No way. That's crazy
We're extremely limited during quarantine you gotta can't really see each other except virtually
But I don't know maybe like we can both
Make sandwiches over the phone and do some... I don't know!
We can like go through each other's pantries virtually
You know what I'm saying, see what we got in like you can put a little recipe together.
I say we still get dressed up
Candles, set those up.
I don't know I think any relationship you just need to build to help you like kind of foundation
Just getting to know each other and everything like that. So just talking simple talking.
Maybe I'll sing to you over the camera
Get to know you better talk music a little more.
I like this
That's all I'm saying and you can set up Zoom and you've got Netflix party and both at the same time
Yoooo, on the projector
I see where you're going there. Yeah
Quarantine cook-up. I like it
Except your food would come out really good and my food would come out like trash. It's a collaborative effort
We're gonna work together on this
We're ultimately narrow it down top pick but first just eliminate two guys
Aiden
I'm sorry. No, it's all good. Thanks for the opportunity
Thanks for keeping me till the finals that that means a lot to me
My boys
Peace and blessings guys. Good luck
Much love
Malcolm
Okay, okay, okay. Hey it's all good. It's all good. I'm got you
Made it to the top three can't complain put my best foot forward and it just didn't pan out
Leesie seemed like a great girl, would have loved to get to know her
Overall I just think it was great that we had this opportunity to connect and explore
Given the present circumstances so it's all good
Jonah you're just goofy
You're just funny as hell and I really like that
You've been making me laugh this whole time my cheeks hurt. I can't stop smiling and
Elijah I feel like we get each other on
Like we both are like religious and how you're explaining your house and stuff and the date. The date got me
Oh my gosh, this is like the end
No matter what you choose I think that, you know, that it's the best choice for you so.
Good luck
C'mon Elijah!
You both
Made this experience
Worthwhile and fun. So I think if I were to go on a date with one of you
The person's date that caught my eye more
was Elijah
But Jonah, you are funny bro!
It was a great experience, um the best man won obviously clearly oh
Just really
Really glad to be a part of it. This is a really great experience. Honestly.
I'm gonna leave y'all to it
So did you think you were gonna win I
I didn't think so. Actually I
Did this thinking it was just gonna be a fun time but a cute girl came on and I was like, whoa
Maybe I can win. Well, I at some point I don't want to do this now, but I'll get we can get each other's numbers
Yes!
Huge thanks to Bumble for partnering with us on this episode. We want to remind you guys that during this time
It's better to stay safe and date from home. Spend this time getting to know
Somebody so that by the time you have your first date, it doesn't feel like a first date
Be sure to download the Bumble app using the link in the description below. Thanks for watching